ha hier ist mein nightjet 21:40 Uhr nach
Wien Hauptbahnhof ach so ach der fettes
Budapest sogar von gleich 9 da müssen
wir hin und damit ey Leute was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem Video
ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich bin auf
meiner Reise nach Istanbul mit dem Zug
und wir fahren jetzt nach Zug geil wir
befinden uns hier gerade auf jeden Fall
in Zürich Hauptbahnhof und ich muss euch
mal folgende Story erzählen eigentlich
habe ich mir für heute nach den night
Chat gebucht privates Schlafabteil mit
Dusche und so Frühstück ja dann haben
die mich vorgestern angerufen von meinen
aus sorry leider war das schon vergeben
und dann stand ich halt ohne Zug da dann
haben die mir einen anderen Angeboten da
gibt's allerdings nur so ein ja
geteilten liegeabteil und ich habe halt
gezwungenermaßen weil ich diesen Zug
brauche du gesagt das heißt bei mir
können gleich auf fremde Leute im
abteiligen und ich habe keine Ahnung wie
es wird ich habe sowas noch nie gemacht
aber ich dachte mir ja kommen machen was
einfach machen deswegen haben wir jetzt
8 Stunden nach Wien und ich hoffe es
klappt gut weil ich brauche dringend
schlafen naja zu kommen in 20 Minuten
ich warte und wir sehen uns bis gleich
so Leute was geht ich wollte euch einmal
kurz erklären was ich genau gebucht habe
was dann bei der Buchung schief lief und
wo ich dann am Ende gelandet bin wobei
ihr das auch gleich sehen werdet das
ganze nehme ich jetzt logischerweise im
Nachhinein auf also ich bin schon längst
wieder zu Hause es gibt fast täglich
zwei verschiedene nachzüge die von
Zürich nach Wien verkehren einmal ist es
hier der euronight und der nightjet so
wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe
verkehrt der Euro night aber ab Zürich
auch unter dem Namen nightjet also wird
dann auch mit NJ irgendwas abgekürzt
mein nigities ja auch irgendwie genau
nj467 oder irgendwie so halt eigentlich
habe ich hier im nightjet so ein
Schlafwagen gebucht für 159 €, das ging
auch alles durch ganz easy geklappt also
dass wir auf jeden Fall super nice
gewesen ich habe gesehen dass der
Youtuber Celtics genau diesen
Schlafwagen schon mal getestet hat check
das gerne aus wenn ihr euch für
interessiert weil ich konnte den jetzt
nicht testen die haben sich nämlich dann
bei mir gemeldet und können ihn
alternativ jetzt diesen euronight
anbieten und bin dann halt im Liegewagen
gelandet ja auch absolut neue Erfahrung
für mich schauen wir mal was wird also
super wie ein bisschen aus wie der
letzte Nachzug okay wo müssen wir hin
[Musik]
so ich muss zu 317
mein Zimmer teilen oder was
[Musik]
okay
also hier ist jetzt 66 und da oben darf
ich dann schlafen das geht ja ich hoffe
einfach es kommt keiner hier rein das
wäre so geil Alter der Waggon ist auf
jeden Fall deutlich besser als der
letzte Nachtzug den ich hatte naja
schauen wir mal wir sind auf jeden Fall
nur zwei Sachen eingedeckt
[Musik]
schon besser nicht gibt's hier nicht
also geht zumindest noch nicht an ich
hoffe es kommt keiner oder einfach nur
irgendwie der meint wegen korrekt ist
gar kein Bock auf so komische Menschen
deswegen kann man ja verstehen oder
[Musik]
Leute ich weiß nicht ob ich lachen oder
weinen sollen wirklich ich dachte ja ich
habe das Apartment für mich am Ende vom
Lied wir waren zu fünft und der eine
hatten Kontrabass dabei das passt gar
nicht Alter zum Glück konnte einer ist
noch eins weitergehen also wir sind
jetzt zu viert aber ich weiß auch nicht
wie ich da schlafen soll naja ich habe
es mir selber ausgesucht auf jeden Fall
jetzt schnell Zähne putzen und ich leg
mich dann einfach hin ich kann jetzt
halt nicht so viel hier mit Film ich
versuche morgen noch was zu filmen es
ist eh draußen dunkel wir sind jetzt
gerade losgefahren vor 20 Minuten und
dann hoffe ich dass ich da schlafen kann
weil ich brauche wirklich schlafe ich
kann schlafen komme dann wird morgen tot
anstrengend weil eigentlich wollte ich
noch meinen Pulli wechseln und meine
Wäsche aber das kann ich jetzt nicht
mein Rucksack ich da irgendwo in der
Ecke kann ich jetzt nicht wieder dran
ich habe jetzt hier mein Kulturbeutel
Nachzug fahren ist schon auch hart
zumindest in diesem Liga Abteilen die
heraus jeder kommen wir so ein Typ
entgegen der hat so eine eierquetsche an
also ja okay ist das normal hier bei
euch aber anscheinend ist das so eine
Erfahrung muss man auch mal machen aber
ich sage jetzt schon Liegewagen mit vier
anderen die ich gar nicht kenne
schwierig aber augen zu und durch ich
einfach mit Fußpedal geht das hier
ich raste aus oh Mann
so Leute so sieht das hier aus alle
schlafen jetzt das ist dann auch
irgendwie so normal glaube ich dass
jeder sich direkt hinlegt und schläft
also die Kollegas von mir meine besten
Freunde die waren jetzt schon ich gehe
da rein und melde mich dann morgen ich
stell mir einen Wecker für 6 Uhr und
dann bin ich schon fast in Wien Digger
keine Ahnung wir schauen einfach mal was
dann passiert bis morgen man muss dazu
sagen ich habe ja auch generell am
Vortag nicht viel geschlafen war den
ganzen Tag unterwegs und bin dann abends
in diesem Nachtzug gelandet und wollte
einfach früh schlafen gehen man hat aber
auch eigentlich gar keine andere Wahl
wenn man sich mit fremden Leuten das
abteilt hat weil die wollten halt auch
alle um 22 Uhr schlafen gehen dann ist
er das Licht aus du kannst ja noch am
Handy chillen aber das war's brauche
jemand Licht unten super gute Nacht und
ich hatte zum Glück meine Noise
Cancelling Kopfhörer dabei weil der eine
Typ hat so geisteskrank geschnarcht ich
habe es durch diese neues kennst den
Kopfhörer extrem laut gehört und konnte
eigentlich ab 3 oder 4 Uhr kein Auge
mehr zu machen hatte dann halt irgendwie
meine 45 Stunden Halbschlaf da
und dann habe ich mich dazu entschieden
okay ich stehe jetzt auch kurz meine
Zähne und setzt mich einfach vor die
Treppe zum Ausgang warte bis wir in Wien
ankommen und steigt dann aus und bin
froh wenn ich da bin kann das nicht
verstehen wieso man so rücksichtslos da
alle voll schnarcht dann fahr halt
einfach nicht mit zum Nachtzug meine
Meinung Leute was geht guten Morgen boah
Alter ich habe wirklich wieder so
unfassung geschlafen
versuchen wir haben jetzt gerade
und dann sehen wir uns gleich
em467 der Verkehr hier aber es nightjet
ah Leute ich hätte den Zug sogar bis
nach Budapest durchnehmen können aber
irgendwie ging das nicht mehr also war
ausgebucht
ich habe mich jetzt frisch gemacht jetzt
so aus wie der letzte Mensch aber die
meistens richtig so Leute was geht ich
habe es geschafft in Wien hinter mir ist
noch bei Nachtzug und der fährt jetzt
weiter nach Budapest das doof ist da
muss ich auch hin aber ist nicht so
schlimm ey wir haben jetzt ich Digger
ich fühle mich halt wirklich wie früher
als ich gerade aus dem Club kam um 6:30
Uhr oh mann war das eine Reise ey der
Typ neben hat schon wieder so unfassbar
geschneit wieso macht man das und geht
in so einem Abteil klar ich da alle zu
dass sie nicht pennen können wenn man
ganz genau weiß dass man schneidet wie
ein LKW also ich habe noch nie jemand so
Schnarchen dann wie den Typen ich gehe
mal kurz noch ein bisschen weiter nach
vorne und dann macht man eine Bewertung
des Nachtzuges also eins kann ich euch
versprechen ich werde nie wieder
Liegewagen fahren und auch erst recht
nicht für den Preis also ich habe
eigentlich noch schlechter geschlafen
als im Nachtzug nach Kopenhagen und da
waren die Betten wirklich ehrenlos hier
ging es jetzt eigentlich fit aber ich
konnte halt nicht pennen weil der die
ganze Zeit geschnarcht hat im Abteil
waren 37 Grad wir waren halt zu viert da
drin auf für die Leute von euch die
öfter nachzufahren und sagen ja Alex
mecker nicht so rum tut mir leid aber
für mich persönlich so ein liegeabteil
sich mit drei fremden Menschen zu teilen
schwierig und er ist richtig für 125 €.
so während der Zug dann noch vor mir
steht und jetzt gerade abfährt sage ich
euch noch mal
ciao ciao ich hoffe ich habe nichts
vergessen hey wo ist eigentlich mein
Kaffee warte mal genau gestern Nacht kam
noch der schaftler bei uns rein und
meinte ob wir einen Kaffee haben möchten
um 6 Uhr einen Tee und ob wir einen Keks
haben wollen oder einen Käsebrot und ich
habe gesagt Kaffee und Käsebrot aber der
kam nicht um 6 Uhr toll kommen wir zur
Bewertung kommt vor naja das Bett war
okay alles andere war grausam also fand
den Wagen von der Ausstattung deutlich
besser als den letzten nachtjet aber es
war halt so stickig und die Lüftung und
so hat alles irgendwie nicht so richtig
funktioniert wahrscheinlich weil wir
halt so viele waren zwei von fünf Sterne
Essen gut wurde mir gesagt gibt was aber
hatte anscheinend vergessen oder ich
weiß nicht kann ich nichts zu sagen ich
habe mir auch nichts geholt 0 von 5 weil
das halt vergessen hat Service ja ähm
gut ich sag mal so der schaffen aber
ganz nett machen wir mal zwei von fünf
gut gemeinte zwei von fünf
naturerlebnisfaktor na ja es waren
Erlebnis es war sogar ein ziemlich
wildes Erlebnis für mich aber ich habe
halt nicht so viel von der Natur gesehen
ich weiß aber dass die Strecke
eigentlich cool ist deswegen wenn man
die tagsüber fährt man sieht halt Berge
und so deswegen würde ich da mal also
Zürich gute Strecke 4 von 5 Sterne und
zum Schluss Preis Leistung ich habe
jetzt 124 Euro bezahlt fand ich schon
super viel ich weiß nicht wie teuer der
Bums ist wenn man ein bisschen früher
Bucht das war jetzt nicht dieser obb
nightjet der fuhr aber unter dem Namen
nighted jetzt ab Zürich soweit ich weiß
aber da gab es halt nicht z.B diese
einzelnen Schlafwagen mit Dusche und so
ich habe gesehen der Youtuber Celtics
das geht schöne Grüße hat dazu ein Video
gemacht also check das gerne mal ab
verlinke ich euch mal hier irgendwo weil
eigentlich wollte ich damit verkehren
nur in meinem Zug gab es halt keine
schlafwägen deswegen Preis Leistung
würde ich sagen zwei von fünf ja so 60
70 € wäre okay gewesen aber ich habe
halt wirklich unfassbar schlecht
geschlafen eigentlich hätte ich auch
gleich auf der Straße schlafen können
meine Reise geht auf jeden Fall jetzt
weiter wir fahren nach Budapest ich
glaube das wird der kürzeste Trip da
fährt man nur drei Stunden oder so hin
und dann muss ich da auf jeden Fall
erstmal ein Hotel und ein bisschen
klarkommen und ich habe auch noch gar
keine weiteren Tickets gebucht also ich
bin gespannt es gibt schon geile Züge
jetzt noch bis nach Istanbul aber welche
das dann für mich sein werden wir
herausfinden abonniert den Kanal wenn
ihr Bock habt auf die weitere Reise wird
bestimmt noch witzig wir sehen uns Leute
haut rein ciao